welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show number eighty five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight hanging out
together through the coronavirus
lockdown Brooke in Kentucky around the
Ben Shapiro show engulfed heartbroken
hey Ben good to speak to you the
governor in Kentucky has taken
aggressive measures to limit the spread
of 7:19 in our state that includes was
in schools last week and then livening
bars and restaurants to only carry out
in delivery last night but recently
there was a resident that tested
positive for the virus but he left
against medical advice and refused to
self quarantine so police are now
stationed outside of his home to ensure
that he doesn't lead to spread the virus
I just want to know what your take on
this is this setting a dangerous
precedent against personal liberties
ignoring due process and the Fifth
Amendment is it's a slippery slope or
our desperate measures called for you
know desperate times
so Brooke I do think that state and
local authorities do have an enormous
amount of power and they always have
actually in times of public crisis and
the question is whether it remains
temporary or whether it becomes a
permanent sort of thing if it's a
permanent sort of thing you're talking
about permanent violation of rights if
you're talking about a temporary thing
Abraham Lincoln suspended habeas corpus
in wartime Franklin Delano Roosevelt
took measures that certainly violated
civil liberties during wartime so did
Woodrow Wilson some of those were for
good some of those were for bad some of
those were over the top some of those
were necessary you know the question is
to you know somebody who's refusing to
self quarantine right now who's been
diagnosed with corona virus the governor
I'm sure has authority under the state
constitution to do what he is doing if
that lasts beyond like let's just say
the governor decided you know what I'm
locking down everybody forever obviously
that would be a sort of a different
story during public health emergencies
localities and states have an enormous
amounts of authority I spoke with a
former attorney general Jeff Sessions
yesterday on the show and he said
exactly the same thing this has always
been true once it starts to become
permanent we should always be zealous
and guard our liberties at the same time
we did give local and state government
the ability to protect us from
externalities and when you're talking
about the spread of the pandemic that is
a fairly significant externality Brooke
really appreciate the call and you're
right we should be vigilant about our
liberties at the same time we got a
balance in the need to protect ourselves
in something like this situation Linda
in Roseville California on the bench
pure struggle for Linda
yeah hi Ben I have a cure I've been
listening to the news to try to hear
something about how our military and
their readiness is dealing with the
corona virus and also how their families
are doing yeah I mean I haven't heard
anything either Linda and honestly I'd
like to hear from some members in the
military date five five two three six
thirty to twenty eight to see how this
is going obviously military bases tend
to be kind of close quarters you know I
would assume that that the military is
doing its best to space people out and
ensure that there is their social
distancing but frankly I haven't heard
anything either Linda and you're right
that is a hole in the media coverage so
I hope somebody will pick up your tip
here and give us a little bit of
information about how that's going I
know that you know on the completely
other side of the spectrum
America's prison system could be just an
absolute hotbed for kovat 19 I mean
you're talking about people in close
quarters not particularly
sanitary cramped conditions and not a
lot of medical facilities so now there
are a lot of questions to be asked about
how exactly this thing gets controlled
Linda really appreciate the call Jeremy
in Pennsylvania you're on the bench pro4
Jeremy you back the question I have is
that I've had some conflicting reports
here I typed in on back to work in
Google search and oh come all these news
articles on here saying in China life
returning normal as coronavirus outbreak
contained do you feel as if the Chinese
are actually on the other side of the
curve and if it's too soon to tell or is
there any way that we could correlate
that with our own response I mean our
own response has to be almost as good as
China's if not better to contain this so
that will give us some sort of a model
going forward I mean they're they're
more dense later than we are so you know
is there is there something there that
we can hope you know Jeremy that is the
big question is how good is the
information coming out of China now I
assume that Apple has been keeping tabs
on the spread of coronavirus in China as
well and Apple just recently reopened
their stores in China they're still
closed everywhere else so that would be
a good indicator I would think that
China has actually gotten past it but
again who the hell knows and we also
don't even really know what measure is
China took is sort of the problem here I
mean China is a black box at Beijing for
example literally in the last few
minutes just expelled the American
journalist from the New York Times Wall
Street Journal Washington
VOA news in time from the Chinese
mainland Hong Kong and Macau so who the
hell knows what they are doing behind
the scenes you really don't have any
idea I mean it's the Chinese government
they have not been exactly shy in the
use of physical force against people
they disagree with I mean that for all
we know they could have gone into the
hospitals and done something terrible
the people who are actually suffering
from Koba 19 and now they're on the
other side of it so yeah it's hard to
take a lot of a lot of inspiration from
from China I'm hoping the question I
have is whether South Korea is getting
back to work because they did a good job
locking this down but is the lockdown
over there continuous or are they
getting back to work either I we just
don't have enough information at this
point Jeremy about agree with you we
need to see some evidence of somebody
coming out of this thing before we start
getting too optimistic I have a quick
question if that's okay sure I just
watched it from I just want talking the
live coverage of the another coronavirus
update and one of the reporters asked
him really without asking if he was
planning on a nationwide I assume he
meant by that martial law and Trump
really shied away from that saying he
didn't feel that that was a good idea at
all do you think if you know where do
you think the tipping point is for that
for a nationwide look honestly if we if
we were talking about a disease that
affected everybody of every age equal
and you're talking about 20% pandemic
rights then then you would be talking
about a nationwide lockdown if however
you are talking about protecting elderly
people and you're talking about doing
this for like a year no I don't think
that's gonna happen I don't think anyone
has any taste for a nationwide lockdown
or frankly do I think that anybody has
the resources to even enforce a
nationwide lockdown of the sort that
you've seen in Wuhan China for example
already coming up we're going to bring
you more updates on kovat 19 everything
Koba 19 related the president held a
press conference today the federal
government finally getting on top of
this thing trying to get its arms around
it but what conditions have to prevail
in order for this to be successful we'll
talk about it is the Ben Shapiro show